hello my name is Veer Das and I feel
unique about being Conan O'Brien's
friend because I'm pretty sure I'm the
shortest friend he has globally
I do have you in my cell phone as short
as friend globally right yeah and I
always know exactly how tall are you I'm
five foot eight okay not bad but that's
not bad no that's that's a decent height
is Tom Cruise your shortest domestic
friend well we're not really friends I
say we are but then his lawyer contacts
me and says stop saying that uh no I
don't know how tall is Tom Cruise
he's like five six or but I think he
does wear boots
five seven is what they list them online
yeah yeah he's got little lifts yeah do
you think he would jump out of planes if
he was three inches taller
I don't think so I think he'll bring up
a really good point I think when you're
lower to the ground you have less you
have less fear of gravity that just
makes sense I am a very personally Brave
man you know that Sona no okay
um but because I'm six four and so far
from the ground I'm I'm terrified of
doing my own stunts
that's why it has nothing to do with
coordination or your athletic ability
it's because you're tall those are
factors those are factors
I would like to see you go out and hunt
for a stunt double that would be a great
episode of something yeah I I should I
should someone who is my height and has
my weird characteristics yes of and my
strange torso to leg ratio uh which is
way out of balance yes let's do that
let's find me a good stunt double okay
are you gonna go the opposite way and
they'll get someone who's like super
jacked and be like always funny when the
stunt double doesn't come close
it's up there comedically with when they
cut to a dummy and they've made no
attempt to have it match so someone's
running to the window and then a
differently dressed dummy is thrown out
the window and there's no articulation
of the limbs so arms are bent it's just
a flailing sock-filled dummy falling
that always makes me laugh I uh I know I
won't take his name but I know like a
Bollywood star who signed a big movie
that was uh set in the ocean right and
and he I don't think he read the script
like Legend is he didn't read the script
and he signed this big movie and uh
showed up to like workshops before the
movie and workshops were like in a
sports complex with a pool and they were
just diving people there and he's like
what the hell is this and they're like
we're gonna give you diving workshops
and he's like I'm afraid of water I'm
not going in the water and then he
looked for the first time at the title
of the movie and it was Water World and
there like so 80 of the movie is set in
the water and so he's like I will only
go into waste deep water and then they
pick the skinniest stunt double in the
world
so in this movie every time he's
underwater he's skinny and he has a
six-pack and then he comes up just fat
as off
very nice of you not to name names but I
really want to see this now I had we
were talking just before the show but I
I had a project once uh it was for
American Express and it was a really
great idea I really loved I loved it and
it was in Jaipur and I remember just
before I went
um you know when you travel you get to
different shots and so I went to this
specialist who tells you here are all
the things you have to do he asks you
where in the world are you going when
you tell him he says okay these are the
things I'm going to give you the
following shots uh and then he said okay
where you're going
um I have one rule for you which was
stay out of water okay don't go in water
he's and I said you know why and he went
on to describe uh he said well there's a
power parasite and it can swim up your
penis into your body and then it will
Nest there and it will slowly feed on
you and you'll die slowly over years he
says so stay out of state of water and I
said oh okay definitely uh well this is
a problem and he said why and it's
because there's a part in the commercial
that's a main part of the commercial
where I'm Waist Deep in water
and
um it's kind of important to the
commercial I'm there helping these other
women uh uh you know wash these these
garments and that's important and I'm
supposed to be in water and he went huh
who's a commercial for and I said
American Express and he said you do what
you got to do
so I did it was fun I did it yeah it was
fun did you get a parasite you know what
I did but it only enhanced everything
yeah my penis is much larger now yeah
I've had no complaints that's a tagline
you never see American Express
you're impotent but no credit limit